so bringing - back ET he wasn't in las
film he's here he is are you treating
him well on set yeah josh is very cool
yeah no he's uh he's a good guy you know
we have a lot in common we both he's got
a small child and you know we love golf
and you know we've met each other a few
times before we started working together
I actually was the first one who told
him that he'd be coming back oh really
I told him that a golf event I don't
think he'd believe me but he told me
you're a lefty - I'm a lefty - yeah yeah
that's good that's cool
and neither his son is like three years
old and here's your daughter now she's
probably 13 Wow how's it going is it
getting easier is it getting harder oh
you have a nine year old females are
pretty dramatic no we're not yeah yeah
is she is she regretted yes yeah yeah
but you know she's also my little angel
so did she want go into acting no I
don't know well it depends yeah what day
it is now talking about Michael Bay and
being on set with him he did a facebook
video showing us the background of
transformers you're actually in it did
you show him how to use a selfie stick
he knows more about that stuff than I do
I'm still very old-fashioned I'm just
learning how to tax the email and
FaceTime you know I can see him as a
director and you as a producer would you
ever do that I mean you're these are
ballers like all the best shows possibly
you never know we've been talking about
doing a couple of other projects
together so maybe at some point you know
and bothersome I'm a huge fan meets the
rocks on it joins the best I love the
rock yeah my favorite that's my favorite
role - and he's the best as it is
do you think you should run for
president uh if he wants to do you think
you'd be a good president uh what pretty
good compared to some of the choices out
there today but I loved Wayne I don't
know if he wants to go into politics
seems pretty stressful work tell the
rock to call me Dwayne call her see you
told your husband okay yeah that's okay
I just want to work out with him really
oh cool yeah it'd be great wouldn't it
all right then sure
like that like like for protein that's
that's sure he eats a lot he's got long
very large portions of food he got
something and if you could take any car
and turn into an autobot what would it
be ah my Toyota minivan oh wow a minivan
my Sienna minivan do you really have a
minivan yes I do
come on mark I Drive them in you don't
have a minivan I have a minivan how's it
go how is the minivan cool tinted
windows black it's all blacked out
blacked out hydraulics on it no
hydraulics but it's got a satellite TV
and it's very low key so the minivan
Mart not going to be bothered by it
though you know for kids you got to
embrace it my wife won't get in it no
she's not having